okay lastly again questions related to
coronavirus and so on and so forth
David Donald Trump has been utterly
incompetent in dealing with coronavirus
can there be emergency removal of Trump
for failing to deal with coronavirus
listen the emergency removal of Trump
for failing to deal with coronavirus is
voting in seven and a half months that's
that's it okay if the idea again we set
it with the molar probe we set it with
impeachment we're not going to remove
Trump with impeachment we're not going
to remove Trump with an indictment we
are not going to remove Trump with the
twenty-fifth amendment it's seven and a
half months until the presidential
election is scheduled to take place I
don't know what could be done
hypothetically about saying Trump's
Trump has perpetuated the spread of a
pandemic when we could have been
controlling it since a month ago three
weeks ago I get it it's incompetence its
dishonesty it's all of those things but
the way to remove the guys to vote them
out in November that it plain and simple
and then actually get adults in place
get a president in who would never say
something like I know more than the
doctors I don't care what the doctors
say I don't care what the scientists say
I don't I don't care what other
countries say I know more than the
doctors the doctors are regularly
stunned by how much I know about this
that's weaponized malignant narcissism
we've got to get it out and I think we
are all you know instead of focusing on
could we emergency remove Trump because
it's not going to happen let's focus on
take control ourselves of making sure
that we aren't doing anything that could
spread the contagion that means staying
home working from home not hoarding
supplies that cause people to have to
drive around even more looking for a
roll of toilet paper let's all work
together and if we do that and it's a
big if because we seem to be failing in
many ways if we do that we can hopefully
turn around what are very very
concerning numbers coming out in terms
of new cases that would be my approach
as I've been saying for years in
November we can remove Trump between now
and then let's behave correctly
let's do
the right things we've got a great bonus
show for you today get instant access to
the bonus show by becoming a member at
join pakman.com or by becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david excuse me
slash david pakman show